one minute time control a war zone rated
118 players 1760 is the average rating
time handicap if you did not know
already the times are adjusted according
to both players is rating 30 minute
tournament no experience level required
tournament starting now let's roll let's
go here double the points get this
little thing out of my way oh no not a
good way to start don't you dare mmm
just give me the air hit me with the air
I don't want it to start now if you're
not gonna start within the first five
seconds
don't even start it I'll hit me with the
air and give me my point or two probably
just a point come on let's go here look
at look at what I'm faced with a clock
in a clock and nothing else look at the
time tick tick tick tick tick tick tock
tick tock let's go come on come on hit
me with the air let's go it's a minute a
minute has passed let's go there's
probably somebody with two games in
already okay good close out what do we
got give me points one point okay it
took a minute to get it but I'll take it
all right let's get a game in though
let's roll here come on I'm in ninth
place now I'm getting picked okay I'm
paired up honey honey 2010 each pond
launched it it's launched uh-oh ah a
center and the Queen's coming out the
Queen's gonna be the big bad wolf
let's do this I'm not moving fast why am
I not moving fast get that clean nasty
pin I come all the way back with my
queen - H - ah this is a juicy square
get rid of that Bishop look for Forks on
c7 in the night n f5 primary reason why
I played here I want my night to get to
f5 queenside castle he's got to go get
out of there oh I get material where's
the king gonna go he's got a play here
Oh ah I got the bishop and the Queen and
the pine maids check and then this is
double check me nice I'll take it five
four three here we go
this guy the big bad wolf right here
literally 2053 Sicilian what ok Sicilian
closest alien and the oh they're going
in this direction interesting um about
the bishop and I got to stop why am I
playing so passive here I guess it's not
super passive but let's stop g4 maybe
that pawn is pinned no bishop don't you
dare try to get here in hey my knight
queenside castle are they lined up some
battery whoa
now that's scary hmm I got to do this
I'm in trouble
run for the hills just castle where it's
safe sort of Oh coming under heavy fire
what's happening here okay my bishops on
a good diagonal this is a nasty diagonal
ball right here very scary
oh man
man oh I want to cry defend please just
defend bishop do something good do
something good I have tricks up my
sleeve if the Queen plays here tricks I
have tricks up my sleeve go here pre
move it oh man oh man oh man it's very
scary I don't have any time and I gotta
win this you can do it oh man is this
scary
am I getting made it oh my bishop has a
home how much time right here I have my
bishop covering this square oh they're
gonna take my rook no no no no no don't
win don't you dare don't you dare win Oh
what do we have
Oh the bishop is gonna kill me or is it
I just want to give a check pre moves
pre moves pre moves where the Primo's
I'm dead I'm dead run for the hills run
for the hills run for the hills
I'm not meat eater I'm I'm out of time
I'm out of time I don't have any time oh
man I got a comeback like a maniac now
ah how did I let that one slip away I
couldn't get those sneaky pre moves in
ah that was painful man I was trying to
move so many times I couldn't move I'm
blaming on the mouse
man come on this is killing me right
here this is killing me I'm coming back
though I'm coming back or am I has 11
points I'm up there with a proud one
point I'm sitting proud with one point
right now and I got a night in the back
pocket though so this one shouldn't be
bad Oh
pre moves I can't get these pre moves
down let's go you can recover from this
can't you I'm not gonna win
so how it's gonna be a win on time I'm
not gonna win this game in a regular way
so I just have to not let any seconds
come off of my clock pre move the rest
of the game
let me just practice prima lives in this
tournament or in this game you know what
I meant let's go let's roll they don't
have any time anything just move okay
back to tournament five I'm in 18th
place let's go here on e Sicilian oh my
king was ah was he running around scared
in that game
let's go fish if I know my opponent is
well aware of the fishing pole sneaky
tactics and they are not castling
kingside
or are they half three hang on f3 Bishop
d6 mmm Queen here Bishop here making one
threat I'm on the Queen resigned time
just take that night he's still there
take the bait h2 there it is back to
tournament 11 oh I'm in 12th place
somebody has 19 though 19 a bunch of 12
and then 11 okay I'm hunting down that
first place guy don't you think I'm
gonna go away into the night quietly No
come on you could do it you could do it
land a fork what's good what's going on
with that king he's going nuts
maeín one thread Oh
check no I want me oh they're gonna do
it go ahead do that and take my night
take the night he's free
take him me yes it's back to tournament
sneaky tricks everywhere the assassin is
up there the assassin I'm trying to
track down the assassin but I have to
get through to jae-hoon 1992
jaehun okay it's engaged Queen c7
casting the line the line is cast Knight
g4 prepare it to being prepped Queen
right here is a defense or is it I have
Bishop there on the night uh-oh H files
opened up come on silly Primo's making
to threat mm give me that pun wolf Ponk
just push here oh I've gotta save that
let's do this where's that Queen goin
mates coming up okay slick move let's do
this and now I'm gonna take you do this
and then run away with my king a little
bit just can't Oh haven't smell slipped
get out of there Queen just bugging me
come on looking for me and one rook F to
is mate in the corner it's me back to
term in twenty nine still in it oh what
a speed bump early on let's go Lance
Lance one minute
tournaments here all right you could
still get this don't you dare give up no
way
the big bad wolf got me ah the big bad
wolf let's go over here and then there's
probably tactics against my night being
a protected Knight f4 be wonderful if I
didn't dropping stuff no no at the end
of it I get the bishop if there's Knight
takes here doesn't quite work I'm
getting material now okay so it's not a
quick win but it still should be a win
assuming I have a decent amount of time
to work this stuff out I was gonna do
that anyhow I'm on the pond pigs on the
rook and the a2 pond a7 pond that
doesn't work this tactic cuz I throw in
a check at the end
okay now this bishops out of the game on
the 9th and the Bishop to d4 mates if
the rook goes elsewhere keep this
structure right here having this
structure keeps the bishop out of play
Knight coming in to f6
Oh f6 on the cards trouble and they're
on that okay may the knight can't move
the boo they can't move there in a giant
now that's made that's made that's made
back to tournament where we got 4150
who's this guy that has 50 link let's go
still gonna try for this no no no I
don't want to accept your gambit no no
Smith more gambit accepted declined okay
they're prepping this a5 move still
gonna play it here we go
here it is what's the scoop
take them it's probably free the king
could run for the hills temple gainer
Bishop on a good square Bishop on this
square just go here should take that
bishop soon maybe actually Knight right
here might be good mate and - oh not so
fast light square weaknesses uh-oh big
trouble hmm
Bishop takes pawn I don't want to take
with my pawn I wanna take I want to look
for mating - what's a mane - threat to
me - or is it let me hit the Queen first
it's probably something better than that
check check
I even know what that's doing I should
play here no I drop stuff it's this
night after they don't have any time
okay I take that rook anything give a
check like this and come back no time
anything back to turn 55 66 55 16
minutes and change somebody is 42 siren
all right let's go siren 16 minutes and
change and let's roll here with f4
Knight f3 and hopefully Castle Knight
here it could be a giant pain it could
still be a pain okay make up your mind
take I gotta run oh my queen
oh it's scary you got to go Bishop
cannot deal with you get out of there
okay now this now the smoke is cleared
and I should have pinned no that would
drop stuff Queen here where does my
bishop want to be I want to push here
kill the knight Bishop h6 rook takes
Knight soon there's got to be something
juicy here there it is can right there
there's Bishop h6 check uh-oh big
trouble here
let's keep my Bishop around and look
where's the mate my dark square bishop
oh right here takes is the threat it's
for me
coming up unavoidable it's me back to
tournament 71 he's got 84 Oh less than
15 minutes can I get that guy I need to
keep winning I need to keep winning too
it's not enough to just try and catch
that guy I have to make sure I keep
winning as well could slip up at any
moment
these guys flying can I still try and
hit him here we go
each to be very scared be very scared
each 289 he's got it 89 84 hook line and
sinker
here we go Jared let's go Jared oh man I
was just ready to come up with a really
corny line right down you know if I
could share that one
and it doesn't even make sense my first
thought was to play fresh I don't know
that's bad I know it's bad I'll stop
doing that but Oh play fresh right here
Jared
here we go night here if the bishop goes
to d6 it's not going to d6 looking for
tricky fork spawn takes pawn push can I
get it
oh I'm on the bishop I'm gonna take that
one and that one and then just defend a
little bit take pieces support my Center
and then this extra piece is gonna be
good
soon double up on the D file looking for
mates
where are the mates I need a flight
square just so things are nice and cozy
and coming up Queen trade converge on g7
is the plan let's try that rook no check
okay let's go g7 g7 is where I want to
be right now I could do this with Czech
I'm on the rook where's the mate are you
kidding me are you kidding me there was
a perpetual check oh they had a
perpetual check they had a perpetual
check they're being pre movers oh that
would have been brutal they had a
perpetual check in a position like that
can you believe it oh it was there it
was there no stalemates they're gonna
let their clock burn clock burner my
clock burner jared back to tournament
109 102 I have a lead there's still 12
minutes left
okay whoa light squares give me the
light squares here okay Center now what
Oh skewers skewers everywhere
get out of there clean and now I could
push here the Queen that wasn't on that
anymore I should have just denied take
tonight it's free the pac-man mode ah I
had pac-man mode right there just gobble
up everything I'm dropping stuff now
let's just take that I want to open this
up hit the night open this up okay let's
not get too careless here okay right
here this has to be good
deadly fork very deadly no time Oh me
and two if the knight moves maybe
there's something with that mating to
the knight has to come back here to
defend on this C 2 square that's gonna
be TKO time isn't it
or they just gonna let the clock tick
less than 10 let's see I'm gonna do it
anyhow they're not moving back to
chairman 129 101 that guy slip-up he
might have slipped up or maybe he's
ready to win 10 minutes left this guy
again didn't I hit this guy with the h2
square earlier all I remember is the cat
I know it was a cab that I was PI I
think
okay let's chop this up castle and get
this in and I'm gonna take and now
actually hang out of that pond okay cuz
now okay get out of this okay hit this
weak point okay be for to support that
and where's my dark square bishop want
to be capture like this and get him
bishop here to here alright Bishop d4 I
think there's a good spot
actually my knight wants to get back
here for Forks and this is a pivot
Square my bishop I think might want to
go elsewhere let's do this first
I'll work around that night a little bit
that pawns dropping crap what's the
count
oh it's very tight still what a pain
that Knight is such a pain
stay connected Queen here look for g7
he's got to go and then what
okay post up here I want to take with
the pond so I have a check on this
square push again it's gonna be a push
let's come back and then oh I just my
seventh rank is vulnerable right now uh
I just I could have dropped that pawn
queen trade
I wanna get hit the king I just dropped
material oh I want to get hit the king
okay they're not they're keeping that
closed check they might miss the Queen
trade they might miss it I'm gonna run
pond run run run run run run oh there's
a rook check I'm dead
why they do that why do they do that
that shouldn't been played well they're
down on time just hang on to this sneaky
pawn move sneaky pawns sneaky pawns hit
a bishop promote
right here anything there down on time
did you turn it
149 141 141 two guys right there in my
heels
Oh can't be easy can it oh let's go here
double the points see five for the win
and okay
I miss played it once again I keep
forgetting about that
III move I need to be in a spot to play
d5 and now I have d4 and now I have be
five in so the bishop is shut out of the
game my dark straight Bishop wants to be
here and I'm gonna go with this even
though I'm dropping it okay what about
here probably a good spot more
weaknesses inside Castle Knight is
pinned I get this guy Knight g4 coming
up main soon lookin for the quick mates
Knight f3 to defend make it one can I
get rid of that night get rid of the
knight open up the h-file queenside
castle if there's a rook right there
okay probably smash through here soon H
file ready to open up take with the rook
mate until if the knight takes the rook
one to just move just move just move
just move just move okay good good good
back to tournament 169 161 161 they're
right on my heels it's a coin flip right
at the end any one of those guys could
win umm alright I'm winning material
here I'm on FF in hand the night Oh
checks this I'm on the rook on the Queen
I'm on em
probably Knight takes is best uh-oh
this is trouble now uh-oh I got the
clean pieces are falling everywhere
checks queenside castle open the
position up anything
Oh more pieces are falling back to
Turman that was pretty quick 189 161
I've a little bit of a cushion but I
think they're ready to win can I get a
couple wins ahead as a cushion here I
need that cushion okay I have a thorn in
the center let's support this there's
gonna be C 4 e 4 or actually none of the
above
okay Bishop g4 okay dark squares where
are they
let's do this and then support that
Knight Bishop takes Knight could be
pretty good let's do this okay that was
a okay let's take this tonight and then
I'm gonna play here Bishop takes Queen
side castle or not so now this bishop is
shut out
go inside castles are gonna be allowed
it's allowed and now I want to open up
the G file let's go G file let's take
this Knight and take here and then here
and then go after the bishop next King
has to get out for that file what's this
Queen up to I have this square covered
I'm gonna come over with this one mate
in one threat Queen check I have my back
rain covered my knights and rooks cover
this and also my Queen Queen has to go
to H 200 came upon push and the bishop
is crunched uh-oh
that's a tough spot very very tough time
back rank mates just make sure there's
nothing sneaky and me in a couple I
think unavoidable
okay back to tournament 209 181 I have a
cushion a couple more wins if I could
get one more win gets up at any moment
three minutes and change can I get this
one if I get this one I think it's close
to being sealed pawn takes pawn is not
good because of Queen h5 how is my
opponent gonna Castle the knight may be
playing here now I have that covered I
have 7f 4 as well on f4 couple ideas
with that Knight move let's open it up
lead in development let's come back you
did your job you got out of the pawns
way back it up mmm please take care
first and then and then here Oh
oh I'm on the Queen Knight moves pawn
push get out of sneaky stuff I'm in
trouble let's do this get the rook or
something wow this isn't clean
oh it's getting scary
oh they're threatening me why are they
getting made threats on me look at this
noise I got to work around him oh he's
got to go this is gonna kill me
oh man this is gonna kill me oh I should
have moved my midnight right there oh
really scary please don't give me make
at the Queen's off the board the Queen's
are off the board
just take my rook please I don't have
any time they're not taking my bro take
my rook oh I'm dead I'm a dead man
I gotta go quicker checks I can't allow
okay they might block with the rope they
can't block with the rope
get out of there Knight
give a check oh oh wait a second wait a
second wait a second
that's a bad move ah they missed it
prima love I need a primo primo of primo
primo anything Primo's pre moves I can't
pray move fast
oh man David Blaine in it again man oh
man holding my breath less than a minute
oh boy I don't know why I do it I can't
explain it
ooh Queen c7 and just Castle I have to
wait for them in the castle before I do
that I do i is this the delayed fishing
pole for 37 seconds to win this one can
I get that Bishop I'm on it twice and
the Queen
where are the maids they're just gonna
let the clock tick
give me that night stop castling oh
that's it that's it that's it that's it
what do I got first I didn't know who
was on my heels oh man all right let me
close out first-place confetti the
long-awaited 2 to 9 191 81 it was much
tighter
midway through good games all